estos supervivientes de un mortífero
terremoto en afganistán caminar entre lo
que eran las casas de sus vecinos ahora
destruidos por el sismo de magnitud 6,1
que ha dejado a muchos sin hogar a niños
dar acordadas alrededor de 2.000 a 2.500
casas quedaron completamente arruinadas
y mucha gente está herida ahora
necesitamos tiendas de campaña y otras
cosas esenciales ratas de gm o de bakará
de rangers si se desata el terremoto se
produjo en el sureste del país en la
madrugada del miércoles golpeando a 48
kilómetros al sureste de la ciudad de
khost la mayor parte de los daños se
sintieron en la vecina provincia de
paktika en la frontera con pakistán los
talibanes han pedido ayuda internacional
para las labores de rescate los
servicios de emergencia del país no dan
abasto para hacer frente a los
frecuentes desastres naturales biniez
menchú
tenemos que asegurarnos de que la ayuda
llega efectivamente a los lugares que se
necesitan y de que somos capaces de
asistir a la gente el consejo noruego
para los refugiados iba a entregar
arreglos de refugio temporal y luego
seguirá con dinero en efectivo
se espera que el número de muertos
aumente los hospitales están abarrotados
de heridos muchos han perdido a miembros
de su familia
que había siete miembros de la familia
en una habitación tres en otra han
muerto ya no puedo hablar mi corazón se
debilita
naciones unidas- ha desplegado equipos
sanitarios así como suministros de
medicinas y alimentos en las zonas más
afectadas el terremoto es el más
mortífero que afecta a afganistán desde